Meghan Markle recently made this
confession there's some incredible shows
on at the moment White Lotus was a
pretty good example of that oh my God
we heard that Prince Harry and Meghan
Markle are big fans of the show here
tonight are they here tonight
they're not too far from here exactly
how do you think Harry Megan would fare
on a couple's vacation at the White
Lotus
I think there would be some dark secrets
revealed
the White Lotus cast was with our Denny
directo celebrating the premiere of
season two which drops October 30th on
HBO Max how are you going uh early
stress there's a lot of anxiety yes
armpit sweat I'm sure you can see it I'm
sort of still pinching myself it doesn't
really feel real
do you think I slept last night I was
hoping you did whenever I stay at a
White Lotus I always have a memorable
time always we are so excited for
legally blunt 3 and Mindy Kaling told us
that she wrote a very juicy screenplay
for you juicy juicy is how she described
it um what do you know about what Paula
is up to I heard that Mindy has has this
amazing version of of our next round but
um I haven't seen it she's ready to bend
and snap again let's go yeah okay Reese
and Mindy also on the blue carpet Taylor
Swift's pal Este High Este how stoked
are you for midnight you have no idea
yeah
okay she's about to drop you out you
heard it here first I won't be home by
midnight it's incredible
foreign